right what ends up happening is once
they start centralizing control by
having their allies in tech ban people
will they win elections donald trump
loses and then the result of this
is terrifying the new york post reports
u.s expresses unwavering support for
ukraine amid russian military movements
the new york times reports fighting
escalates in eastern ukraine signaling
the end to another ceasefire ukraine and
russia issued statements tuesday noting
the worsening of a conflict that has
been on a low summer for years with
countless ceasefires
it's it's picking up and what's
fascinating about this is that
before donald trump this was a major
move
by the existing u.s establishment
intelligence agencies the
military-industrial complex
gaining control getting western
influence into ukraine yeah
and then creating this major conflict
don't get me wrong putin has a lot
to to account for in terms of his
responsibility here the seizing of
crimea
and the the assistance he's providing to
the separatists in the east
but this is the big war this is or i
should say this is one of the big
conflicts
having a lot to do with the gazprom
natural gas monopoly
europe is faced with very high energy
prices they wanted to get a pipeline
from it's called the cutter turkey
pipeline
long story short all of these pieces
come together in really interesting ways
in 2009 as a report by the guardian the
u.s wanted to destabilize syria
because syria was refusing u.s interests
refusing that to allow them to build a
pipeline
that would bring natural gas into europe
well syria said
outright russia is our ally and we will
not harm their business interests with
their gas monopoly
convenient for us there was a civil war
revolution and conflict and attempts to
destabilize syria
occurred and u.s interests are there
even right now reports that the us is
moving more in
so it's unsurprising to me that we're a
couple months out of joe biden becoming
president and all of a sudden ukraine
lights back
up i mean of course it's not surprising
i mean
i think anyone who's even remotely
red-pilled understands perfectly well
there's these international networks
where they work together and joe biden
was their guy
and here's here's what really bothers me
about joe biden this is i think the
worst thing you can say about him and
it's
something that's not even really
particularly controversial if you
in my opinion correctly regarded the
iraq war as a mistake right let's
suppose i was a chef i've used this
metaphor before
and i accidentally undercook some
chicken and someone dies right like god
forbid
as not only would i feel enormous guilt
i'm like okay
i need to take mechanisms if i'm gonna
still remain a chef which i know that i
would do because i killed someone god
forbid
uh i'm gonna take steps to make sure
this kind of thing never happens again
because this is so beyond the pale and
inappropriate i don't know how many
people died in iraq war
iraqis and americans alike if joe biden
says this was a mistake and you feel
guilt over
tens of thousands of that hundred
thousand innocent lives being hundreds
hundreds of thousands of
instant lives or maybe not even innocent
lives but i don't think people
everyone should be killed i would be
like all right i'm going to make sure
this doesn't happen again i'm going to
staff
my white house with people who don't
think this way i'm going to make
steps to kind of put fail safes in place
that i mean he the the the urine in his
depends wasn't dry
before he was sending arms to syria yeah
this is
very disturbing and i gotta tell you i i
you you see these photos of these
hippies in the 60s with the soldiers
and this girl hippie puts the daisy in
the in the the in the barrel of girl
hippie famous photo yeah and as a kid i
thought
what an idiot and now i think you know
what she's not the idiot
because she's really even though she's
maybe not even not particularly
uh whatever sophisticated in her
thoughts she's like you know what this
is wrong
and and we're all raised to think that
war is a last resort
but it's treated as a first priority by
the state and this is one of the biggest
reasons i'm an anarchist
war is so glorified and even when it
happens like everyone's just like
and i'm like do you understand what this
means bombs from the sky
and children and innocent truth is they
don't understand
yeah i haven't experienced you know yeah
yeah you're right i don't even
understand it because right
you know what it is to me the united
states is the capital city in the hunger
games
where they're all totally oblivious to
the suffering of the outside districts
who are being beaten and forced to fight
to the death
and they're like so what and they're
drinking epic to vomit and keep eating
until the war comes to them you see it
was i believe it was the cia that
referred to
um i'll keep the language light okay um
the cia said actions in the middle east
resulted in blowback
yeah that when we were going over there
meddling in governments
arming rebel groups people got mad at us
over there
and they brought it back over here and
all of a sudden the people in the
capitol are shocked what's happening why
is it happening don't worry
they just hit you for your freedoms yeah
some simple answer
so you get these people blindly and uh
ignorantly just
cheering and dancing for the war machine
and then when it comes back to them they
they patch you on that and say oh it's
because of your freedoms don't worry
not realizing that dude maybe if we just
minded our own business a little bit
and worked on ourselves people wouldn't
be doing these things
now there are some serious challenges
though china's expansion into many of
these areas their authoritarianism
they're trying to take over and it seems
like they're doing a heck of a good job
of it which is scary to me
because if they end up as the global
power i don't like the idea of them
gaining influence over us but it seems
like it's happening
happening either way but the thing is
they're not gaining influence over us
through militarily
right they're gaining influence of
religious the same way the civil union
did through surreptitious means through
intelligence uh and through journalism
and thing and getting the right people
uh who are kind of um fans of theirs to
some extent or at least neutral
in the right positions of power that's
the insidious part it's not
china is not going to fight the u.s
maybe through a proxy war like the
korean war where it's not going to be
like a world war iii god forbid
but they are going to do mechanisms to
make sure that their opinions
are presented as um unarguable with in
the states
shout out to the fourth turning which
you're familiar with i believe yes i'm
not stross how generational theory
no so this is book uh about 25 years ago
they just look a little
shocked i'm shook yeah i'm surprised
that michael hadn't heard of that
every every 20 years is a new season and
every 80 years we go through a major
upheaval
oh god i hate stuff like this it is oh
my god
this is like astrology sure interesting
what uh 80 years ago
we had world war ii eight years before
that we had a civil war eight years
before that we had a revolutionary okay
and look every president who was
inaugurated
um it was 1789 1865
1933 and would have been 2005. where was
that 72 years in between
it was washington lincoln fdr so it
would have been george bush's second
term
so yes sometimes these patterns appear
but to claim that they're
kind of inevitable i i really rejected
that i don't think they're unable to
if the implication is that these cycles
tend to repeat i think this is the kind
of thing where you get the conclusion
you force the data to fit it well
perhaps they wrote this book 20 years
ago and they did predict
a certain amount of things and certain
amount of things they got wrong because
that's typically the case when someone's
speculating
but the general idea is it's actually
really simple to explain
strong men make good times good men i'm
sorry strong men make good times good
times make weak men
weak men make hard times hard times make
strong men have you heard that before
i have the general idea is that we we've
seen it with generational wealth it
typically lasts three generations
the individual who came from nothing and
worked really hard and understood what
gumption was
starts a business makes a lot of money
sure then they have a kid the kid grows
up yeah sure slices shirtless in three
generations
right and so that's kind of the general
idea that we we're now entering this
period where you have a bunch of
very entitled people who simultaneously
complain about the police but then
demand that the state be given more
power over many other aspects of their
lives there's a lack of logic and a lot
of what their
you know decision making is i digress
the point is
according to this book we are entering
the winter period which should end with
some kind of calamity but here's the
issue
the problem is that people tend to they
they it's not always incorrect
they base the future off of the past we
should look to the past to try and
understand what will happen in the
future but there's many things you can't
predict because of a change in
methodology and technologies
yes to clarify as many people think
strasse generational theory is
predicting a massive world war with
china
strasshau generational theory says that
each war is fought with the most
powerful weapons of the time
the question we wrote on the show is and
that might be social media no it's love
i think it's lasers yes care bear stare
is the most powerful weapon you know
what i mean a lot of people assume it's
nuclear weapons because
world war ii sure it's been 80 years the
mind control
social media manipulation and propaganda
is infinitely more powerful right now
you can take over a country without
firing a single bullet you can convince
the people to cheer for you
as you storm their beaches i i disagree
because uh
when what's his name um uh he uh he
wrote the book propaganda
and there's uh um this is in the future
there's bernays book and then there's
walter littman's book public opinion
those are the two those were in the 20s
and 30s it would it's a lot easier to
propagandize
look at hitler look at stalin it is a
lot easier to propagandize uh
population without access to independent
media
it's a lot hard look at look at fdr uh
look at lincoln uh look at the the
confederacy it's a lot easier to have
control of that population then
than it is now as counterintuitive as it
sounds it's a lot easier to disrupt
a nation's center power centers with
independent media
then yes correct so what the most
powerful weapon is of today
is not firing a nuke it's china getting
a bunch of sock puppets and bots
across social media to undermine
cohesion in the united states
i'm all for undermining cohesion united
states as you know i'm for
breaking this country up so that sounds
like a good thing to me i'm just going
to take a step back about this book
there's a book i recommend everyone read
by arthur herman who's an amazing
historian his first book was called the
idea of decline in western history
and what he goes through is every 20
years there's a new
sect that says we're at the end of
history the mil it's it's
it's very millennialism in the christian
sense like it's all going to come down
get your bootstraps ready and whether
it's it's the hitler version or whether
it's the the
um greta thunder version it's always
right now it's the end times and somehow
it never is the armageddon so i'm
very skeptical of these books where the
conclusion always is
now is when things are gonna hit the fan
it's always now when things are about to
hit the fan
yeah i feel missed 2006. thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you